OK, então como vocês sabem,
encaminhamos a nossa discussão
para os tipos de estruturas sociais
que são tanto legítimas
quanto contributivas para o
bem-estar dos seres humanos,
devido a nossa natureza.
E acabamos a última aula com um jogo
de representação teórica
que eu chamei de o
dividendo de cooperação,
que envolve o caso de 2 pessoas que,
com medo de que o outro
ataque os seus recursos,
gastam uma certa quantidade de
energia murando os seus bens.
Sendo que, se de alguma forma eles se
encontrassem numa situação
em que pudessem cooperar e
confiar na cooperação,
em vez de protegerem os bens, a
energia poderia ser dedicada
para a produção de
outros tipos de bens.
Aqueles necessário, como diz Hobbes,
para uma vida confortável
e para coisas como a navegação.
Bens que permitiriam
melhorias para ambos.
E nas 2 últimas aulas analisamos
o que diz Thomas Hobbes
no contexto da sua obra, O Leviatã,
que explora tanto por que é que o
dividendo de cooperação
é a tendência a que
todos levem vantagem
como também por que é que, a fim
de conservar a cooperação,
são necessários certos tipos de
mecanismos externos de aplicação
– um leviatã, um monarca ou
líder que tem poder absoluto,
segundo Hobbes.
O que vamos ver hoje e na próxima aula
é uma versão contemporânea
desta questão, que nos
incita a pensar...
se estamos considerando não
apenas a cooperação
ou falta de cooperação
entre 2 pessoas,
mas também a distribuição de
bens e responsabilidades
através de uma comunidade maior...
como é que uma sociedade
deve ser estruturada
se pegarmos como imagem básica
algo semelhante a Hobbes.
Nomeadamente, a ideia de que a
cooperação é benéfica para todos
em oposição à concorrência,
mas que tal promoção da
cooperação estável
requer certos tipos de incentivos.
E, portanto, o que vamos analisar em
particular, hoje, é a discussão
do filósofo John Rawls, que
viveu entre 1921-2002
e que foi professor da
Universidade de Harvard.
Encontramos a opinião de Rawls num
artigo de jornal de 1955;
um texto sobre a punição onde ele
introduz a ideia de uma justificação
de 2 níveis para a punição.
E o que nós vamos conferir na aula de
hoje é a discussão de Rawls
no seu influente livro de 1971,
A Theory of Justice [Uma
Teoria da Justiça].
Assim, a teoria da justiça de Rawls,
que em muitos aspectos trouxe de
volta à discussão filosófica
contemporânea a consideração
sobre um conjunto de questões
que nós rastreamos em A
República de Platão
– por que o interesse
próprio das pessoas
em participar de uma
estrutura social?...
e trouxe isso de volta de forma que
entrou no discurso público.
Uma Teoria da Justiça é
o tipo de livro
que vocês vão ver citado em
processos judiciais.
Vocês vão ver que ele não está
apenas em revistas acadêmicas,
mas também em conversas
intelectualmente fundadas
sobre a legitimidade da sociedade.
E Uma Teoria da Justiça começa
com estas palavras famosas:
Rawls afirma, após dizer o que
ele espera fazer no livro,
que "Justiça é a primeira virtude
das instituições sociais,
como a verdade o é para o pensamento".
Ele destaca: "Uma teoria que,
embora elegante e econômica,
não seja verdadeira, deverá
ser revista ou rejeitada;
da mesma forma, leis e instituições,
por mais eficientes e
engenhosas que sejam,
deverão ser reformuladas ou
abolidas se forem injustas".
Esta é uma articulação
do que Rawls vê
como o compromisso central
de uma certa visão
de legitimidade do governo.
A imagem ocidental – e, talvez,
uma imagem mais geral –
segundo a qual uma estrutura social,
um ajuste de instituições fundamentais
pelos quais as vidas são regidas,
é legítima se, e somente se, as
instituições de apoio são justas.
Portanto, assim como uma teoria
extraordinariamente elegante,
mas falsa, deve ser rejeitada com o
fundamento de que ela é falsa,
de acordo com Rawls, uma
estrutura social
que é elegante, mas injusta, deve
ser igualmente rejeitada.
Ele passa a identificar o que vê
como alguns compromissos
fundamentais deste tipo de imagem.
Ele escreve, por exemplo, que
"cada pessoa tem uma
inviolabilidade baseada na
justiça
que nem mesmo o bem-estar da
sociedade pode sobrepujar.
Por esta razão, a justiça nega
que a perda de liberdade de uns
dê direito a um maior benefício
dividido pelos outros".
Nós pensamos sobre essa
questão – a do trade-
off de bens entre os
indivíduos – no contexto
da nossa discussão sobre o
consequencialismo, por um lado,
e sobre outras teorias morais,
deontologia e teoria da
virtude, por outro.
O que Rawls dá voz
– tanto aqui quanto nos artigos 5 e
26 de Teoria da Justiça –
é a uma outra razão relacionada
com a razão que verificamos
em Bernard Williams: essa
ideia de dignidade.
Outra razão para a rejeição
como uma forma fundamental
de dar sentido à
responsabilidade humana;
o consequencialismo como a
sua base fundadora.
Mas o que talvez não tenha sido
perceptível para vocês
quando líamos coisas como
The Trolley Problem
foi a ligação dessa perspectiva
– a ideia de que "cada pessoa
tem uma inviolabilidade
baseada na justiça que nem mesmo
o bem-estar da sociedade
pode sobrepujar" –
e um dos documentos
fundadores desta nação.
Portanto, entre as verdades que
Thomas Jefferson pensava
como "evidentes por si mesmas" está que
"todos os homens são criados iguais,
dotados pelo Criador de certos
direitos inalienáveis...
... E que entre estes"
– estes direitos de modo que até
mesmo a utilidade da sociedade
como um todo não é suficiente
para substituí-los –
estão "a vida, a liberdade e
procura da felicidade".
Além disso, vocês vão ver
neste documento fundador
– a Declaração da Independência –
que existe uma voz dada
exatamente à imagem da adoção
de contrato que nós reconhecemos
primeiro na sua forma incipiente
na discussão de Glauco sobre
o papel da justiça
em A República de Platão
e de uma forma muito mais
clara na obra de Hobbes.
Então ouçam o que vem a seguir:
"A fim de assegurar esses direitos,
governos são instituídos
entre os homens,
derivando seus justos poderes do
consentimento dos governados."
A ideia de que entrar num
contrato social com o outro
– em que, como forma de
garantir os direitos à vida,
à liberdade e à procura da
felicidade, nos sujeitamos
a um Estado de Direito, que,
portanto, leva a ser legítimo –
é central, tanto para a tradição do
contrato social articulada em
Hobbes e nos seus sucessores
(Locke, Rousseau e Kant)
quanto para este documento...
o que todos nós já presumivelmente
tínhamos encontrado antes.
Além disso, continua o documento:
"sempre que qualquer forma de governo
se torne destrutiva de tais fins,
cabe ao povo o direito de
alterá-la ou aboli-la
e instituir novo governo".
Que tipo de novo governo?
Qual é a resposta de Jefferson?
Um novo governo "baseando-o
em tais princípios
e organizando-lhe os poderes pela forma
que lhe pareça mais conveniente
para realizar-lhe a
segurança e a felicidade".
Então, a ideia que estabelece a
criação de um governo
que ganha a sua legitimidade
através do nosso reconhecimento,
de modo que o nosso interesse
próprio é adiantado,
é uma noção central da
tradição política americana.
Então, como isso se manifesta
no texto específico de hoje?
Como é que John Rawls, neste
livro dos anos 1970,
tenta dar voz contemporânea a este
conjunto de preocupações
que 200 anos antes dele
fizeram parte do pensamento
de Thomas Jefferson e, 150 anos
antes, do de Thomas Hobbes?
Rawls começa dizendo qual é a
sua noção de sociedade.
A sociedade, à qual estamos
tentando identificar
uma série de características,
é "uma associação
autossuficiente de indivíduos
que em suas interrelações
reconhecem a certas regras de
conduta o papel de amálgama,
e que agem, na maior parte da vezes,
em conformidade com elas".
Vocês devem se lembrar que no
final da aula sobre
o Dilema do Prisioneiro e em nossas
leituras da quinta-feira passada
nós analisamos outros mecanismos,
além dos identificados
por Hobbes, para a aplicação
do contrato social.
Hobbes pensava que a maneira mais eficaz
era a imposição de um soberano,
cuja ameaça da punição e do castigo
seria a manutenção de determinados
comportamentos nas pessoas.
Mas acontece que, além disso,
a aceitação implícita da
consciência ou do hábito
de certos tipos de normas de interação
acaba tendo um papel tão
grande, se não maior,
ao permitir que as sociedades
funcionem sem problemas.
E nas leituras da próxima terça
vamos conferir um trabalho
social psicológico que aborda
diretamente esta questão.
Portanto, Rawls expressa o que ele
pensa sobre uma sociedade,
para efeitos de discussão.
É "uma associação
autossuficiente de indivíduos
que em suas interrelações
reconhecem" alguma coisa...
que são "a certas regras de
conduta" como obrigatórias
e, "na maior parte das
vezes"... nem sempre
– eu sei que alguns de vocês falam
ao celular enquanto dirigem –
agem "em conformidade com elas".
Essas regras determinam um sistema de
cooperação que foi projetado
para fazer o quê?
Ele foi projetado para fazer a
coisa que Thomas Jefferson
se referia na Constituição.
Ele foi projetado para fazer
a coisa que Thomas Hobbes se
referia em O Leviatã.
Ele foi projetado para fazer
a coisa que Glauco se referia no
seu desafio a Sócrates.
Elas determinam "um sistema de
cooperação com função
de desenvolver o que for desejável
para o que dela fazem parte".
A legitimidade do governo sobre
esta imagem deriva do fato
de ser a favor dos seus participantes.
No entanto – e esta é a
característica desconcertante
que faz da filosofia política
uma disciplina de grande
interesse intelectual –,
Rawls diz: "embora uma sociedade seja
uma reunião de cooperações
com o intuito de se obter
vantagens mútuas,
esta será marcada por conflitos e por
interesses individualizados".
Por que isso?
Porque existe uma
identidade de interesses...
porque a cooperação social torna
possível uma vida melhor
para todos em oposição
a se vivêssemos
por nossos próprios esforços.
Ou seja, temos dividendos
como consequência de não termos
de gastar a nossa energia
em nos protegermos da ameaça
de dano dos outros.
Cada um de nós – como sabemos
pelas 2 últimas aulas –
é melhor quando podemos
contar com os outros
de uma forma cooperativa.
No entanto, o conflito de interesses
surge em qualquer sociedade
quando "as pessoas deixam
de ser indiferentes
à maneira pela qual o aumento de
produtividade resultante
da sua colaboração é distribuído".
A grosso modo,
cada um prefere uma fatia maior
que uma fatia menor.
Se houver dividendos de cooperação,
isso é bom e produz uma razão
para a cooperação.
Mas, quando há dividendos
de cooperação,
cada um de nós
quer o máximo de dividendos
possível de ser conseguido.
E a consequência disso é
que, embora a sociedade
seja uma reunião de cooperações
para as vantagens mútuas,
ela é tipicamente
"marcada por conflitos
e por interesses individualizados".
Então, isso dá origem à
pergunta do próximo nível.
Quando lemos Hobbes,
lemos apenas o início da sua
discussão sobre o contrato social,
apenas uma parte do final do Livro
1 e do início do Livro 2.
Rawls está se dedicando a uma
questão que vai além disso.
Ou seja, que conjunto de
princípios deveríamos adotar,
devido ao fato do conflito?
Nós estamos assumindo isso como
almejando a cooperação,
algum tipo de estrutura social.
Como resultado, nós
acabamos com mais coisas
do que teríamos se não
tivéssemos cooperado.
Como esse material, esses bens
– uns tangíveis, uns intangíveis
– devem ser distribuídos?
Portanto, Rawls aponta que é
necessário um conjunto de princípios
para escolher entre os
vários ajustes sociais
que determinam essa
distribuição de vantagens.
Estes princípios "proverão a
determinação de direitos e deveres
das instituições
básicas da sociedade".
Coisas como o sistema legal.
Coisas como o sistema econômico.
Coisas como os direitos fundamentais
e as responsabilidades dos cidadãos.
E o que eles fazem é definir uma
distribuição adequada
dos benefícios e encargos da
cooperação social.
Porque, como já observado, a
cooperação social traz com ela
benefícios inegáveis, mas
também alguns fardos.
Num sistema cooperativo,
a nossa liberdade é
restringida em alguns aspectos.
E pode ser o caso de os
benefícios revertidos
para o sistema social irem
para outra pessoa.
Estamos num ponto onde eu
expresso o que Rawls chama
de a ideia principal da
teoria da justiça.
E eu vou explicar a vocês
como isso se encaixa
com a noção do véu da ignorância.
Portanto, como a atenção de vocês
está começando a murchar,
vamos usar os clickers.
Preparem-se para um pouco
mais de verdade e,
em seguida, um pouco de diversão.
Então, a ideia principal de Uma
Teoria da Justiça é,
como eu já apontei para vocês,
algo que faz parte da
tradição do contrato social.
Rawls diz na 1ª nota de rodapé
do texto que ele está
trabalhando, principalmente,
na imagem do contato social como
o articulado em Locke,
Rousseau e Kant, mas que ele
o remete a Hobbes.
E isso, como vocês sabem,
é a seguinte ideia:
que cada um de nós reconhece que
há uma certa vantagem
em viver numa sociedade
onde não estamos
constantemente sob ameaça,
em que reconhecemos que nenhuma
ameaça pode ser alcançada...
essa ideia de que você não está
constantemente em risco
nessa guerra fria de todos contra todos.
Essa "não ameaça" só pode ser alcançada
no âmbito da cooperação geral.
E que a cooperação geral só
pode ser alcançada
sob algum tipo de sistema de
aplicação implícita ou explícita.
Rawls, com esse quadro de
contrato social em mente,
passa a perguntar o que é necessário
para obter uma imagem clara
do sistema de aplicação, caso ele
esteja destinado a ser alguma coisa,
que é o bem de cada um dos
seus participantes?
E aqui está o que ele diz.
"Os princípios de justiça",
da estrutura básica da sociedade,
"são os que pessoas livres e racionais,
reunidas pelos mesmos interesses,
adotariam inicialmente quando todos
estivessem numa posição
de igualdade, para definir os termos
fundamentais da associação".
Ou seja, há 4 ideias fundamentais
que apoiam esta imagem.
As regras que governam a sua
sociedade, as regras que governam
uma sociedade legítima na
qual você deve pactuar,
são regras que você adotaria se
estivesse livre, racional,
com interesse próprio e numa
posição de igualdade
em relação a todos os outros
indivíduos livres, racionais e
com interesse próprio que também
sejam pactuantes desta sociedade.
Como podemos chegar até lá?
Como podemos determinar o que os
indivíduos livres, racionais,
iguais e com interesse próprio ?
aceitariam, uma vez que... nós
não somos todos iguais?
Alguns nasceram em famílias ricas
e alguns nasceram em famílias pobres.
Alguns nasceram com certos tipos
de talentos naturais;
outros nasceram com outros.
Alguns nasceram com certos
tipos de concepções...
ou alguns foram criados para terem
certos tipos de concepções:
da vida boa.
Outros foram criados para terem outros.
A ideia de Rawls é a seguinte: os
princípios que articulam
a estrutura legítima da sociedade
são aqueles que você concordaria
se não soubesse a pessoa que iria ser.
Portanto, ele pede que você
imagine que você está detrás
do que ele chamou de "véu
da ignorância",
onde ninguém sabe o seu lugar na
sociedade, a posição de classe,
o status social, a fortuna na
distribuição dos recursos
e habilidades naturais, a inteligência,
força ou concepção do bem.
A partir disso, onde você não
sabe a pessoa que será,
você obtém o 4º dos
nossos 4 requisitos.
A igualdade.
Porque nada em particular sobre o
seu interesse próprio
desempenhará um papel.
E tendo se colocado nesta
posição imaginária,
onde a ignorância traz consigo
um certo tipo de habilidade de pensar
claramente sobre a questão,
cada uma das partes, em
seguida, determina livremente
sobre a base racional do seu
interesse próprio.
O que nos dá liberdade,
racionalidade e interesse próprio.
O quadro que eles acreditam
que seria o melhor.
Então, a ideia é a seguinte:
um grupo de pessoas
que não sabe qual o papel
desempenhado por elas na sociedade
se posiciona detrás do véu
da ignorância e pensa
como quer que a sociedade
seja estruturada,
se não soubesse se acabaria como
um pastor, um capitalista,
um médico, um trabalhador da
construção civil, um policial,
alguém que tem dificuldades com
a autoridade policial,
alguém portador de deficiência
ou mesmo um jogador de futebol de Yale?
E por trás desse véu da ignorância,
reconhecendo que qualquer uma
dessas identidades
pode acabar sendo o que eles seriam,
esses indivíduos chegam a
um quadro de como é
que a sociedade seria estruturada.
Portanto, ao reconhecer que eles
podem ser muito ricos,
é possível considerar o que seria
preciso para a sociedade
permitir a prosperidade dos
indivíduos sob essas condições.
Mas eles podem reconhecer, também,
que podem acabar como um
trabalhador da construção civil.
Talvez acabem como um médico.
Talvez o conjunto de
capacidades que eles têm
sejam diferentes dos da maioria da
sociedade, e assim por diante.
Então, o que está na
articulação do véu da
ignorância,
como uma forma de pensar
sobre essa questão,
é a versão de Rawls de um tema
que temos visto repetidas
vezes neste curso.
Hobbes diz: Quando você pensar
nas estruturas políticas,
pense em si mesmo como não
sendo diferente dos demais.
Esteja disposto, diz ele, a
renunciar os seus direitos,
na medida em que os outros estão
dispostos a fazer o mesmo.
Contente-se com a mesma
liberdade para os outros
que os outros permitem a você.
Mill diz: as ações são corretas
na medida em que tendem
a promover felicidade,
e erradas se tendem a
promover infelicidade.
Não a própria felicidade do agente,
mas a felicidade de todos os envolvidos.
E Kant, outra vez dando voz a esta ideia
– quando você pensa a partir
da perspectiva moral
não pensa em si mesmo
como especial –,
escreve: aja somente em
conformidade com a máxima a
partir
da qual você possa ser capaz de
transformar numa lei universal.
Portanto, peguem os seus
clickers... vamos fazer
3 exercícios rápidos onde veremos se a
estratégia de Rawls funciona.
Deixa eu explicar como será.
Neste caso, vocês estão decidindo
se inscrever em 1 das 3
seções de um curso.
As aulas do curso são
idênticas em todos os 3 casos.
Mas, na opção número 1, o curso
tem 4 excelentes seções,
seções que ganham um 9/10 nas
avaliações médias dos alunos.
Então, 4 seções são excelentes
e 1 seção é horrível.
E você não sabe em qual
seção você vai terminar.
Então, na 1ª você tem a opção de
ir para a sala e, em seguida,
você será atribuído
aleatoriamente a 1 das seções.
4 delas são excelentes; 1
delas é horrível.
A 2ª opção é que você
pode fazer o curso
e 4 seções são muito boas...
elas apresentaram uma
pontuação de 7/10,
enquanto 1 seção é horrível.
E você não sabe em qual
seção vai estar.
Se você escolher essa, você tem um 4/5
de chance de estar numa
seção muito boa,
mas você tem um 1/5 de chance
de estar numa ruim.
E na 3ª versão do curso,
4 seções são muito boas.
Elas receberam um 7/10.
E 1 das seções é mais ou menos.
E a pergunta é: qual
curso você escolhe?
Você se inscreve no curso que
tem 4 seções excelentes
e 1 horrível?
Lembrem-se que vocês não sabem
qual seção será atribuída.
Você se inscreve no curso que
tem 4 seções muito boas
e 1 horrível?
Ou você se inscrever no curso que
tem 4 seções muito boas
e 1 mais ou menos?
Todo mundo entendeu bem a
estrutura da pergunta?
Eu vou começar a votação.
OK. Tudo bem, então vamos lá.
Vamos ver...
Tudo bem. Portanto, 60% de
vocês estão com... uau!
Onde estão os valores discrepantes?
Pessoal! Todo mundo
entendeu! Que maravilha!
Nós nunca tivemos... para os
visitantes que estão aqui...
esta turma nunca teve 0% das pessoas
com a minha opção irracional óbvia.
Então eu estou contente de ver que
as pessoas estão
realizando um bom trabalho.
Portanto, cerca de 60% de vocês
são assumidores de risco.
Vocês estão dispostos a assumir a 1/5
de chance de a aula ser horrível.
Mas 40% de vocês são avessos
ao risco neste contexto.
Vamos tentar de novo.
Exatamente a mesma pergunta,
cenário diferente.
Então aqui está: você está
participando de uma loteria de imóveis
e pode entrar na loteria 1, 2 ou 3.
Loteria 1:
há 4 imóveis excelentes e 1 horrível.
Loteria 2:
há 4 imóveis muito bons e 1 horrível.
E loteria 3:
há 4 imóveis muito bons e
1 mais ou menos.
Mais uma vez, você não
sabe onde vai acabar.
Pergunta:  você entra na
loteria de imóveis 1,
na 2 ou na 3?
E vamos acionar o temporizador.
6, 5, 4, 3, 2, 1...
E vamos ver o que temos.
Portanto... ah! Vocês não se
importam com a aula,
mas são muito avessos ao risco
no mercado imobiliário.
Assim, quando se trata do
bem-estar de vocês
em termos de infraestrutura de moradia,
68% estão dispostos a
renunciar a possibilidade
de um excelente espaço pela certeza
de não acabar num imóvel horrível.
Então vamos tentar mais uma vez.
Agora vamos para um hospital.
E aqui está a configuração:
Hospital 1: 4 médicos
excelentes, 1 horrível.
Hospital 2: 4 médicos muito
bons, 1 horrível.
Hospital 3: 4 médicos muito
bons, 1 mais ou menos.
Você pede uma ambulância para
levá-lo ao pronto-socorro.
Você não sabe que médico
está de plantão,
mas você sabe que no Hospital 1
tem 4 excelentes e 1 horrível.
No Hospital 2 tem 4 muito
bons e 1 horrível.
E no Hospital 3 tem 4 muito
bons e 1 mais ou menos.
E vamos ver os números
que saem desta vez.
Portanto... 4, 3, 2, 1...
E vamos ver onde vocês se posicionaram.
Assim, quando se trata de
decisões médicas de alto risco,
vocês são ainda mais avessos ao
risco que com os imóveis.
Quanto mais importante for
a decisão global
diante de quaisquer decisões locais,
que tipo de estrutura social
você quer ao seu redor
se você não sabe o papel que
vai desempenhar nela?
A pergunta de Rawls, que
sociedade você escolhe,
se destina a ser uma versão
dessas 3 questões
colocadas aqui para vocês.
Que sistema médico você escolhe
se você não sabe que tipo de
pessoa você será?
E a resposta foi: vocês
escolhem uma em que o máximo
é muito bom e o mínimo mais ou menos.
Que sistema de moradia você escolhe?
Que sistema de ensino você escolhe?
Esses foram os casos especiais do
questionamento de Rawls.
Que sociedade você escolhe por
trás do véu da ignorância?
Rawls é muito claro ao dizer
que a sociedade escolhida
precisa ter 2 compromissos básicos.
O 1º é que, quando somos
pactuantes de uma estrutura social
que governará todos os
aspectos de nossas vidas,
a 1ª condição é que
dentro dessa estrutura
cada pessoa tenha um direito igual
ao mais amplo sistema total
de liberdades básicas iguais
que seja compatível
com um sistema semelhante de
liberdade para todos.
Ou seja, que cada um de nós tenha
direitos iguais de voto,
direitos de acesso a cargos
públicos, liberdade de expressão,
liberdade de reunião, liberdade de
consciência, liberdade de pensamento,
liberdade de pessoa, direito de
propriedade e de liberdade
para ser tratado igualmente no que diz
respeito ao Estado de Direito.
Segundo Rawls, esses elementos
são inegociáveis,
no sentido de que se foram
oferecidos a você
– por trás do véu da ignorância
– a possibilidade de troca
de alguns desses bens em
prol da utilidade,
sem saber qual indivíduo
você seria na sociedade,
você não faria essa troca.
Essa é a forma que Rawls
tenta derivar esses
princípios invioláveis,
vistos no início da
Declaração de Independência,
a partir da ideia de que se
tratam de marcas na areia
que seriam desenhadas em
qualquer estrutura social
em que as partes livres, racionais,
iguais e com interesse
próprio fossem pactuantes.
Então essa é a 1ª resposta de
Rawls para a questão
"que sociedade você escolhe"?
Você escolhe aquela que tem um
direito de base inegociável
no nível do mais ou menos, ou melhor,
no que diz respeito a essas
liberdades fundamentais.
Tratam-se de coisas que não são
negociáveis por nada.
Além disso – e um pouco mais
controverso –, diz Rawls,
por trás do véu da ignorância,
você pactuaria com uma estrutura social
onde a distribuição das
desigualdades sociais e econômicas
seguissem um determinado
conjunto de restrições.
O 1º é: na medida em que as
desigualdades sociais e econômicas
emerjam na sociedade, elas precisam
ser anexadas a posições e cargos
que estão abertos a todos
em condições de igualdade
equitativa de oportunidades.
Se frequentar uma instituição
excepcional de ensino
vai aumentar a probabilidade de
você poder ter um emprego,
em que você ganha satisfação
e recebe uma parcela desproporcional
dos recursos da sociedade,
então é o caso dessas
posições, conforme Rawls,
dessas oportunidades, serem
abertas a todos,
independentemente das
contingências das
circunstâncias
que são irrelevantes para a
possibilidade de se fazer uso delas.
Em particular, os recursos
financeiros da sua família
não devem desempenhar um papel
na sua capacidade de acesso a
essas oportunidades.
Então a igualdade justa
de oportunidades
é a 1ª condição que Rawls pensa
ser necessária conservar,
a fim de que as desigualdades
sociais e econômicas
sejam aceitáveis para você por
trás do véu da ignorância
quando você não sabe quem será.
Além disso, e ainda mais controversa,
Rawls pensa que por trás do
véu da ignorância
seria pactuado entre as partes que
as desigualdades sociais
e econômicas seriam aceitas como
legítimas apenas na medida
em que essas desigualdades fossem
para o benefício de todos.
E, em especial, para a vantagem
daqueles menos favorecidos.
Portanto, Rawls não nega que a maré
alta levanta todos os barcos,
que podem existir casos em que se
permitem as discrepâncias
de renda, recursos,
oportunidades educacionais
ou qualidade dos cuidados de saúde
que – na realidade –
conduzem todos a serem melhores.
Talvez o fato de existir
hospitais de pesquisa
seja de grande valor, mesmo para
aqueles que não têm
acesso direto a esses hospitais.
No entanto, é porque, e somente porque,
essas desigualdades beneficiam os
menos abastados que Rawls
pensa que elas seriam pactuadas por
trás do véu da ignorância.
Além disso, Rawls pensa que
estes princípios...
o 1º , o princípio da
igualdade de liberdade,
e o 2º, que nos diz as condições
em que a desigualdade é legítima...
são o que ele chama de
"ordem lexicográfica",
portanto não permitem as
trocas utilitárias.
Não há liberdade de
comércio para a utilidade.
Se fosse vantajoso para a
sociedade como um todo
se envolver num certo tipo de
discriminação racial
para reduzir a criminalidade, por
exemplo, mas a fazer isso
as liberdades de um determinado
grupo seriam usurpadas,
a consideração de utilidade
não seria suficiente.
Mais ainda, como já apontado
nas imagem de Rawls,
a desigualdade só é
permitida quando a vantagem
vai para os menos favorecidos.
Assim, nos últimos 3, 4
minutos de aula,
eu quero fazer mais 2
enquetes com você.
Se vocês têm os seus clickers à mão,
eu quero ver o que pensam sobre isto...
E se os seus pensamentos
divergirem dos de Rawls,
eu vou fornecer 4 posições para
identificar o local da discordância.
Então vamos começar com isto.
Vocês estão tentando escolher
entre as sociedades.
A Sociedade 1 tem uma renda
média de US$ 100.000
e 85% dos seus cidadãos têm
o direito de votar
e liberdade de consciência e
de religião e afins.
Ou seja, esta é uma sociedade
em que 15% das pessoas
não têm direitos civis básicos,
mas a renda média é de US$ 100.000.
A Sociedade 2 tem uma renda
média de US$ 70.000
e 15% das pessoas não têm
direitos básicos.
A Sociedade 3 tem uma renda
média de US$ 70.000,
mas 100% das pessoas têm
liberdades básicas.
Você está por trás do
véu da ignorância.
Você não sabe se estará entre os
15% na Sociedade 1 ou 2.
Por uma questão de liberdade,
igualdade, racionalidade
e interesse próprio, que
sociedade você escolhe?
1, 2 ou 3.
E vamos ver como estes números saem.
Portanto, parece que a prioridade
lexical do 1º princípio
sobre o 2º não dá grandes
margens à controvérsia.
Vamos tentar o princípio da diferença.
3 sociedades.
Você não sabe o que você será.
Sociedade 1: renda média
de US$ 100.000.
Menor renda: US$ 10.000.
Sociedade 2: renda média de US$ 70.000;
menor renda, US$ 10.000.
Sociedade 3: renda média de US$ 70.000;
menor renda, US$ 20.000.
Você não sabe o que você será.
Que sociedade você escolhe?
E vamos ver os números que saem no
princípio da diferença.
OK.
Portanto... ainda... huh...
Não tanta diferença
quanto eu esperava.
Interessante ver que a maioria de vocês
– mesmo aqui – é igualitária.
Avessos a um aumento na média
se o custo é pago pelos
menos favorecidos.
Então, para aqueles que
estão nos 27% aqui
e para aqueles, de forma mais geral,
que não adotam o quadro de Rawls,
quero destacar 4 posições diferentes
onde vocês podem estar se
afastando dele.
A 1ª é que vocês podem
discordar com ele
sobre os tipos de princípios
escolhidos por trás do
véu da ignorância.
Vocês podem pensar que o
"raciocínio maxmin"...
na seção 26, ele diz, por trás
do véu da ignorância,
as pessoas seriam avessas ao risco.
Elas distribuiriam os bens de tal forma
que os menos afortunados
seriam beneficiados.
Então, você pode negar que, por
trás do véu da ignorância
dos princípios expostos por Rawls,
seria escolhido o que seria escolhido.
Você pode negar que é a
escolha feita por trás
do véu da ignorância que
representa o que pessoas livres,
iguais, racionais e com
interesse próprio
aceitariam como termos
fundamentais de sua associação.
Ou seja, você pode pensar que
o véu da ignorância
não é um dispositivo eficaz
de representação
para responder à pergunta que
Rawls propõe responder.
Ou você pode pensar que o que as
pessoas livres, racionais,
iguais e com interesse próprio
aceitariam como termos
fundamentais da associação
é o definido pelo véu da ignorância,
mas isso não determina o que é justo.
Ou você pode pensar
– e vamos considerar essa resposta
na nossa aula de quinta –
que não é o caso
de que a 1ª virtude das
instituições sociais seja a
justiça.
Mas que, em vez disso, existem
outros valores mais fundamentais
no centro da legitimidade política.
E nós vamos voltar a essa
pergunta na nossa próxima aula.